here we go again Sony have unveiled the
PlayStation Plus offerings for the month
of October 2019 you can get your mitts
on these from Tuesday October the 1st
let's not mess around let's do this
first up is one of the greatest games of
all time The Last of Us remastered the
ps3 classic which received updates to
both visuals and controls to play even
more sweetly on the ps4 for those that
don't know the Last of Us is a story
driven survival horror game with a heavy
emphasis on action stealth and adventure
if I oversell this one is due to this
being my favorite game of all time so
please take what I say with a pinch of
salt playing completely in third person
we fill the boots of Joel who is tasked
with escorting a teenage girl Ellie
across the u.s. oh and did I mention
this is post-apocalyptic United States
we cannot trust anyone as they're either
out to steal our belongings or worse
still they may be zombie like creatures
suffering from a fungus which forces
them to eat the last of us see what I
did there you'll be creating improvised
weaponry such as nail bombs or baseball
bats with scissors attached so yeah this
is definitely amateur themed game but
don't get fooled by the b-movie premise
the acting and storytelling are
breathtaking
The Last of Us received so many perfect
ten out of ten scores it's frightening
but of course polygon made sure the
great scores ended with a 7.5 out of 10
sometimes I feel like they're playing
different games to everybody else The
Last of Us has a sequel dropping in
February next year so what better time
than right now to jump back in and save
the world the second game is great if
you live in a country which actually
plays this game but may fall flat in
many others this is MLB the show 19
Major League Baseball hitting home runs
on game day is only one part of the show
character creation training and game
modes which include elements of
management are all here as most people
watching this don't play baseball think
of this how you would NBA 2k or FIFA and
that's pretty much what's going on but
with baseball instead to celebrate the
show being on PS Plus for the first time
the devs are also giving away free
in-game content for those who download
and log in between the first
31st of October this includes five
player packs which contain a diamond
player for your team if you've never
played a baseball game then give this a
go you never know what this could be
your favorite sports game but you just
don't know it yet the review scores also
agree this is a great game 8.5 out of 10
and above so come on be honest are you
going to try it and also have you ever
played a baseball video game before I'd
love to know so there we have it what do
you think happy sad delighted glad let
me know your thoughts but please please
please try The Last of Us
it's a masterpiece I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade it's been a pleasure
see you next time
[Music]